This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by sat for luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Wow.
Your mom's house.
Christina.
Here we are.
Gene.
Uh,
I've got a guest coming up.
Should be very fun.
Yeah,
she's on her way.
Alison Rosen.
Rosen's coming in.
She's my new best friend.
She's everybody's.
She's my real life best friend.
I love what I love Allison.
She's great.
Yeah,
no,
I'm very excited that she's joining us.
It's been a long time since I've seen Alison.
Yeah.
We had her on a,
my God maybe back in the Redondo days that long ago.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
we didn't,
we took a hiatus from guests as we two years with no guests.
That's pretty nutty,
dude.
I have some people come up to me back then and go,
um,
so I just,
I guess I just,
I'm not allowed on your show.
You don't want to have me.
And I'm a,
we haven't had someone in a couple of years and then they got,
yeah,
okay.
Yeah.
Comedians are getting very offended and we're like,
no,
it's just we don't have the space for years within.
Even now,
some people will be like,
Hey,
um,
I tweeted you about doing your show.
I'm like,
what are you fucking 14 I know like dude,
send me a text or email me and not booking you from a fucking tweet.
Like you know me in real life we have phone numbers,
asshole or email.
Yeah.
Or people like Idm due.
I'm like,
on what?
I don't care.
I'm not,
I don't fucking look at my apps.
No.
And look at those messages or try Facebook.
Do you?
So,
so does every other lunatic.
I know.
So we are not looking at Facebook messages.
Get your life.
Yeah,
I guess some people and also if you,
if you have something to send to the show,
don't fucking Facebook it.
Not so good.
More like,
oh,
I sent you a link.
You never played it.
I'm like,
where did you send it?
I send it to you on Facebook.
I'm like,
dude,
I've said it a hundred times on this show.
Yeah,
send it to the g male.
We don't go off of Facebook.
No,
I don't play stuff from tweets.
It's just the email account.
That's it.
Yeah.
There's a mom's podcasts,
right at Gmail.
There's a central place for a fucking reason,
man.
Yeah.
There was no house in the email address.
Your mom's potash.
CAS as email,
send it there.
If you have a link,
if you have an instrumental,
if you have a song you made,
that's where we,
that's what we check all the other shit.
I don't,
I don't check it.
I don't fucks with Lincoln debt.
I don't fucks with Lincoln.
Didn't,
no way not happening.
Oh my God.
I just,
I feel like I'm still burping up by a barbecue.
Oh,
let's tell them the story.
my phone.
Yeah.
Here's the,
uh,
ah,
I wasn't ready to die.
All right,
here we go.
Here's the open.
No,
so this one,
Ooh.
Almost fucked that up.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
So there is a trend line here,
which means that richer countries tend to have lower rates of open defecation
then third countries.
But India then,
Huh?
Really
far from that trend line outlier.
It looks different.
It's not centered.
What's going on?
You want me to send her at Harlan?
Boy,
that looks really weird.
Hmm.
All right.
Better?
I think so.
Yeah.
Right.
That looks funny to me.
I Dunno.
We can never get these fucking things locked off.
Right
work.
Yes,
I know,
but I'm saying we got the next week it'll be like,
I know we need to get these cameras mounted on the walls.
A blue man.
That's your next project,
dude.
We talked about it.
We thought we would discuss it.
Um,
I think this might be my favorite intro clip of all time because you were going
to love it.
Well,
it incorporates some of my favorite elements.
There's the intelligence of the Tedx talk,
the seriousness with which she's talking about it.
Yeah.
And then shitting in public,
uh,
brought this up.
So,
oh my God.
I was listening to episode four 37 and choosers talking about India.
And I remembered a youtube hole I fell into last week.
There's a Ted talk about the awareness of shitting in public course.
I had to watch and 32 would enjoy and love the podcasts,
constantly laugh out loud and get strange looks at home from the wife Ben Bad
Ben.
Yeah,
because we were talking about public defecation.
That's a really big problem in India.
And you ever talk about that with your Stepdad?
Is that how this came up?
Well,
no,
not about that.
But when he came to the states,
he didn't know that you could sit down on western toilets.
You thought you stood on them,
right?
Yeah.
So he would be squatting and his roommate walked in on him once and was like,
what are you doing bro?
And he didn't know that you could just sit directly down.
Uh,
but no,
he wasn't.
He didn't shit in public or anything.
No,
but I remember we,
I remember we were talking about public shitting.
Yeah.
And it's a problem in India.
It really is.
Cause they,
they,
they're trying to curb it right now and people are upset about it apparently.
And they don't know.
They don't want to be,
they don't want to be told not to do that.
Yeah.
I mean,
imagine you're used to it and then someone's like keep,
it's like a toddler.
Like you can't do that because it's,
it's great that anytime you have the urge to shit,
you would just drop trial and just go.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Like aren't you,
I mean,
it's directly related to poverty.
I don't know if it's,
you know,
the funniest thing we've ever talked about this.
I don't know why a man that makes me laugh.
I've seen a guy shit in an alley.
We were,
we were thinking about living.
I saw a guy,
shit downtown.
I'm just going to talk about,
it's a time we were looking at lofts.
We were considering this.
The same guy.
Yeah.
America.
Yes.
And the alley and memory.
And he was,
he was standing,
he was barely squatting.
That was,
that's what I remember most about it.
He would just,
he would,
he was bent at the waist like he was,
he was leaning over a just try to see something,
you know,
it's almost like look down there and you just lean.
That's how he was shitting.
I remember him vividly.
It's so funny you have the same memory of that.
I think he had mental problems so,
no,
I think so.
Oh,
stop it.
I would guess you don't wait.
You don't think he was like a banker or a lawyer?
I don't think so.
I think it was also because he was barefoot that gave that away.
I mean maybe it was Saturday.
Was his day off?
If you don't recall the weather that day,
it was a hot summer day downtown.
Almost moved it downtown.
How nasty would that have been?
It's,
it's popping right now.
Places that's where it's at,
but it's not our lifestyle now cause we like the country club and suburbia.
Yeah,
that's urban living,
man.
Could you imagine?
Here's a problem with downtown La is they're like,
well,
okay,
the rent is like five grand.
It's crazy.
Oh,
did,
did you want to park?
Okay.
That's another thousand dollars and that's five blocks from here.
And then you've got to walk in the middle of the night.
They're literally the price people out it down.
Do you guys don't know if you don't know la well,
but they used to be such an undesirable place to live and not even a long time
ago.
Wasteland.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're talking in the last decade downtown has completely changed.
It literally was a place where they just pushed all the homeless into those
Igloo houses.
It was just a place for homeless people and crack heads.
All the homeless were mostly,
you'd see them the most in the toy district,
which was,
I always thought that was so ironic.
You know the terrifying coin.
We make toys for little kids and you see like guys walking naked across the
street and you still,
and that's the thing is then it's not a hundred percent cleaned up.
So you'll go toilet strike once that sun goes down,
all the zombies come out.
And it is tariff.
What's south?
West?
Downtown is really nice.
Restaurants and art galleries and it's very hopping.
It's very nice.
And if you're young and you're cool,
like that's the place to be.
You don't want your fucking kid looking at guys taking shits.
Maybe you do.
Um,
yeah.
So it's a real issue here.
You know,
many households in rural India don't prioritize having a latrine.
So let's compare India to some other countries in the world.
On the vertical axis of this graph,
we have the rate of open desiccation in the country.
I mean this is an actual talk.
That's the crazy,
I know.
This is like,
you're a good serious,
she's smarter.
She's such a strong performer.
She's so smart.
No,
I know this girl smarter than both of us
and that's what she's spending her time.
So there's a trend line here,
which means that richer countries tend to have lower rates of open defecation.
But India is really far from me.
He met as an outlier
outlier used for that night.
Neither of in,
in that way.
Usually it's for exceptional people and things.
What if,
what if the talk here
and that's what I want to address.
Nobody shits like we do and she dropped her pants and she takes a shit on stage.
My family comes from the line of high strong performing public desiccators.
Lot of shifts
better poor than India on this graph,
46 of them have a lower rate of open.
I just love open defecation.
I've never even heard open devotees.
Equine diarrhea.
It's one of those catchy phrase,
open defecation,
equine diarrhea,
diarrhea,
open defecation.
Oh Man,
I've never heard those two words.
Open defecation.
Oh Man.
Have you ever shit outside?
Never Shit outside.
No.
I don't think I have.
Not once.
I peed outside a bunch,
but never,
never having been really shit my pants lately in a long time.
Although I gotta say yesterday could have happened damn.
Who were lounging and we were about to order.
It was like around lunchtime.
Like let's get some lunch.
What should we get?
And um,
you know,
you said,
I really feel like getting some Thai food and I just go,
okay,
I want it.
Flavors.
Yeah,
I down for it and let's do it.
Thai food.
And you say the place that you like,
the quality spot is closed.
They're not,
they're not.
Okay.
So then
all the other places give you open defecation,
use it.
Open defecation was coming up.
We had ordered so we can work from somewhere else.
Now they're dirty.
There's some nasty places around here like you don't want to even know about.
Yeah.
So,
so then the next move was,
um,
I go,
all right,
what do I want?
And I was like,
I want something.
I want meat.
I had a steak,
you know,
the night before.
And probably two nights,
I just want something different.
Like,
oh,
let's do some barbecue.
And I bring up are different.
It's very different.
So I bring up one spot and you're like,
Nah,
I places open defecation.
So then we settle on another place and I'm doing it through,
I'm doing it through the APP and I got to watch the rest of the talk.
We're to know I'm going through the APP and I'm just Kinda,
you know,
I'm tired.
I just kind of,
I'm not really paying attention.
Like it's like,
what do you want?
And you're like ribs cool.
Full rack.
Yeah.
Another one.
Yeah,
of course.
Full rack.
Yes.
And then I'm hitting yes to like the signs and just Bup,
bup up,
bup,
bup.
You know I do the whole order in 20 seconds.
That guy drops it off at the house and when I saw a lot,
this is like a big bag
to see how many other people is a party in the back room or something.
So I start unloading the bag on the table and you're like,
Whoa,
this really is,
because you're pulling out like these metal bins,
like picnic style or people are like ripping lids off and it's like an 11 by 18
you're like,
what is this shit?
A lot.
It's a lot.
What did we do?
We start unloading.
It is way too much food.
I mean there's way too much.
So much.
Well we ordered okay.
A half slab of their onion rings.
Yeah,
but half order it was,
it's been enormous.
Nobody can eat all of this.
Then you've got a baby back ribs and the beef ribs,
it looked like dinosaur ribs.
They were so enormous and they had candied get outta here but finish on them.
It sounds good.
But then I want to vomit.
I know it's too rich.
It was just overwhelming.
And it was also,
I think it was good but it was too sweet.
And I burped it up until like 10 o'clock last night.
And like,
here's the thing,
we took shifts,
the shits smelled like barbecue.
The burps,
every bark I peed last night and my piece smelled like barbecue.
I don't know.
Infiltrated every orifice and,
and,
and system in my body.
Well,
cause I took it down.
I took two shits this morning and I went in after you took your dumb and it
smelled like barbecue.
My piss smelled like barbecue last night.
Crazy.
And then we see this is the thing,
you order these things called burnt ends.
And then I'm like,
well what are they?
The ends of their dick tips.
What they do is they,
they,
cause they use the whole cow or,
or wild.
They make this and they,
they,
uh,
saute the dicks and then cut off the tips and the burnt ends.
That's what it did.
That
the funny farm movie when he's eating the yeah,
the balls.
Yeah.
And they called them like rocky mountain oysters or something.
Rocky Mountain Oysters.
Yeah.
These are just dick tips.
Just the tips and they're nice and Bert.
Really good.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Piece of Bacon.
And the onion rings and then the and what else?
Oh,
corn.
We had corn on the cob.
It was too much.
Well anyways,
we had fucking so many leftovers.
Tried to offer them up to people and I was trying to give them the neighbors and
they were like,
no thanks.
No thanks.
Yeah,
that was bad.
You know,
we haven't gone out like that in a while.
I tell you what,
I've been reigning it in the second
trimester.
I haven't,
I haven't really blown it up with my eating and that,
that was a,
we just went,
we went crazy.
I went for,
um,
for a walk after that.
Yeah.
After that meal,
just to like,
I felt like I owed it to myself.
I went for a lay down.
I had to lay down the rest of the day.
I was so fucked up from it.
It was,
it was pretty wild.
No,
no good.
No good.
I know there's,
there's some meals like that where you go,
I'm going to have the,
I had that and I'm good now for,
I don't like it.
I could have,
I can't,
I know I could not even eat last night.
And then this morning I didn't want to eat and like I'm pregnant.
I have to eat like I was lighting,
excuse me,
light headed this morning cause I'm like,
I physically don't want to eat anymore.
Yeah.
What I have to anyways,
so you and I also,
we don't normally watch these,
um,
you know,
Oscar movies.
I think you and I kind of the outliers of the,
uh,
that world where we don't give it,
I don't,
I generally don't give a shit.
I don't care what wins awards and I don't want to see bomber.
We don't like white bomber cancer.
The guy with one leg and I don't fucking know,
she still loves him anyway.
I don't want to hear it.
But we watched the shape of water.
Now you are away shooting your,
your movie.
I watched it on the flight to shoot
the very first flight there.
Okay.
Because I have,
the way that the,
the movie is set up is it's a a drop.
I'm,
I'm on a drop pickup schedule,
it's called where they,
I shoot for a week and then I have a few days off,
then I go back and I shoot and then I have a few days off.
So it's back to reload your loads.
Right.
For the scenes.
So cause they literally take every ounce out of me.
Right?
Yeah.
Anyways,
I,
I have time off so,
but back and forth.
So anyways,
on my flight there,
Octavia Spencer,
who's in shape of water is in this movie.
She is,
yeah,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
I met her the other day.
You're kidding.
I didn't,
she's fantastic.
She's,
you know,
I heard a story about her and my acting class that she was one of those people
that didn't hit it until much later.
And she got turned down for Grey's anatomy and was like beside herself.
Like she was one of the final people and casting to make it.
It's between her and this other chick and she didn't get it.
And she was like depressed for a year.
Well,
what do you know the help comes around that movie.
Yeah.
And because she didn't do Grey's anatomy.
Guess what?
She's free to do the help and now,
so it's like one of those wonderful stories and Showbiz.
I made a joke after that that her to the producers of the film,
because it will sit in like a little video village.
Yeah.
And they laughed a little too hard.
I was like a,
I got,
oh,
I was talking to Octavia.
She asked me if you could,
uh,
come by later for like some acting tips.
And they were like,
ah,
like laughing.
I'm,
they're like,
can I imagine you are teaching her how to act?
I was like,
Huh.
They're like,
they're like wiping their eyes.
I was like,
all right,
come on clown.
I was like,
okay,
go deliver your funny part.
Yeah.
She was very sweet though.
Very sweet.
Um,
but in that movie,
the Michael Shannon Plays Richard the,
uh,
my God in the shape of water.
No.
What else has he been in?
So people who haven't seen it,
Michael Shannon,
he's got,
he's one of those guys that you recognize immediately,
but I don't know that guy.
He's such a good dead pan.
He's such a good,
miserable Dick.
Like he's a great actor.
He's not,
he's so fantastic.
He's got a great face.
He looks like it eats rocks.
Yeah.
This guy.
Oh,
I just love him.
He was,
um,
let's see.
Oh,
he did at home with Amy Sedaris.
How funny.
I love that show too.
It's so silly.
Yeah.
It was like,
he does 10 boardwalk empire.
He,
I remember him when he played that,
uh,
that killer.
Um,
of course Richard person remember that.
Okay.
Who's that movie?
The iceman seat.
Yeah.
I ain't got to Tom's favorite.
A member that one mud.
That's similarly,
we named our son after.
He's somebody you've seen a hundred times.
He's always the creeper.
Yeah.
He's a good creeper.
God Damn,
you've got a real,
he's got a real serious creeper.
Look to him like his eyes look like,
you know?
Yeah.
He looks like he's,
he means fucking was going to fucking rape.
Yeah.
He's very serious actors.
So you were watching the shape of water?
I actually wanted to see it because I saw a trailer for it and I,
and I liked that.
Guillermo,
what's his name?
I like,
I like Latin filmmakers.
I like whatever he's,
yeah.
So I wanted to see it and I knew you watched it and I was bummed that you'd
watched it.
So sometimes we watch movies when you're away,
we watch them together and then we'll kind of recap together.
It's like we watched it together kind of thing.
Now Richard is a character he plays,
I don't want to give away too much,
but in our estimation,
this guy has the comedic relief of the home
movie.
Absolutely.
By far,
the funniest guy in the movie is Richard Michael Show.
Holy Shit.
He has the best lines.
Funniest guy.
And then I was watching the movie and I was,
I was definitely laughing.
I'm again,
I'm on the flight watching it and I'm laughing at some of the stuff,
but then there's a part in the movie,
so I call you.
I tell you,
I saw the movie,
I tell you it's a good movie.
And I go,
I lost my shit.
Like I really laughed hysterically like member last week or a few weeks ago
when,
when a blue band made me laugh so hard with labeling the file.
Yeah.
That's by the way,
sidebar,
my favorite titles,
forever clips have been guy who's as long infection,
his instrument and homeless man gets raped by gay goes.
Yes,
go ahead.
I had to say before I forgot it.
Yeah,
but so go.
So I'm sitting there laughing so hard and I tell you this and you go,
oh,
I'm going to watch it and I bet you I can guess what is the,
uh,
what you laughed at.
And I was like,
oh,
this is a great game.
This is by the way,
homeless man.
Um,
one of the original,
uh,
we should play this for doctor drew when he comes to homeless is going on there.
Put that on the list were Dr drew anyway.
And then it was so fun because I would wake up and I would be,
you know,
to,
to shoot a movie,
you get up,
you fucking call times like seven 30 in the West,
have to be there.
And then the cruise there at four.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Crazy.
It is long hours.
But it's been,
I've had the best time on this,
but the fun thing is I would wake up and because we're three hours apart,
I would wake up and you,
and it'd be all your guests.
You'd be like,
oh.
So I would wake up,
I check my phone and you'd be like,
it wasn't this or that.
And then you'd be sleeping.
So I'd write back like great guest.
I did laugh at that,
but that's not the moment.
And then I'd get off of the work and you'd have new guesses in there.
It was a fun game and it's fun because I feel like every time Richard opens his
mouth,
it could have been a moment because it takes place in the 60s so it's very
inappropriate,
very sexist,
very racist time.
And that's the best part is that Richard is like totally indicative of that era.
Oh,
he's a piece of shit and it makes me laugh.
I love that stuff that makes me laugh so hard.
The inappropriateness.
Sure.
And he had so many great moments and I,
I'm not going to give away too much,
but it definitely wasn't ultra violent part and I hadn't,
I was off by a moment like I feel like,
right.
And the moment that you cited was like funny did it,
did you giggle?
I feel like the moment that you,
that you thought it was actually made me go like,
oh,
okay,
oh my God.
Oh,
okay.
And then like a hint of joy,
but in an Oh my God way,
you know,
like,
Oh shit.
But the part that actually what I told you made me laugh.
Fuck that.
I laugh so hard.
And of course what made me laugh the hardest was a,
the act of what I was witnessing and like that,
that it was happening,
but also the other actors in the scene being there,
same as like that Henry a thing.
It wasn't so much that he did it.
It's that the other accurate people are there going like,
Holy Shit,
just for the people that have seen this movie,
I know how annoying this conversation,
so I won't give anything away.
I'll say the scene that I thought it was a Tom would find the funniest,
let's just say there's a gunshot and an extraordinary place and the way Richard
handles it handles the man literally bananas.
So I thought for sure that was number one.
Yeah.
There's a part where he gets romantic with his wife.
That doesn't make me laugh too.
That's definitely on the lawyer was,
yeah,
that was,
that was very funny when he was,
when he made love to his wife.
Hilarious.
Yes.
But the moment that won that I wasn't aware of is it has to do with his fingers.
Yeah.
Which is a constant
theme of Casa theme,
but uh,
their demise or how that,
how way,
how they,
uh,
how that storyline kind of finishes.
Let's put it there.
Yeah.
Now,
when I told you,
what did you think,
did you go back to remembering that scene?
I did.
And I,
and I thought like that makes sense because a,
it's really inappropriate.
Yeah.
Be,
it's extremely painful and vulgar.
Yeah.
And you're enough of a derelict,
a degenerate to find that funny,
that moment.
Because that moment by definition for me was,
it wasn't funny.
What did,
what were you going through during the scene?
That one was more like,
oh,
that was an interesting choice for him.
Like I literally,
I didn't get grossed out.
I was like,
cause I could,
I knew that was going to happen eventually cause that's kind of guy he is.
And I was like,
oh that would suck to pick two to clean up is what my thought was for her,
for Octavia Spencer being like,
Oh dude,
yeah,
she's got to clean that up.
This poor woman cleans for a living and now she's got to clean this fucking
thing,
you know?
Yeah.
But I didn't,
I didn't think that that was the funniest.
No,
no.
Yeah.
So you know,
you think you know your spouse and then,
yeah,
I'm very funny.
All right.
Jesus.
Everything okay.
Yeah.
I'm just going to check on stuff here,
making sure everything's okay.
Well,
some other interesting things going on.
You mentioned to me that,
uh,
you have some changes in your own family dynamics.
You know,
I,
I don't know,
man.
I got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just wonder sometimes,
like,
am I related to anybody who's remotely fucking functional and normal?
Like what do you think?
You've know,
you know,
all my relatives,
uh,
is there anybody that is just a fucking normal and,
and I know people,
what is normal?
Okay,
here's,
here's what is normal.
No personality disorder,
uh,
no alcoholism or drug addiction.
No severe depression that cripples you or prevents you from doing things in
life.
Yeah.
A functioning,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
that's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's,
let's do that.
So,
uh,
I haven't talked to my father in a while for various reasons.
I won't go into,
but let's just say we,
you know,
we're not,
we're not speaking right now,
but,
so I heard through the grape vine through,
uh,
my cousin,
that celebration,
a celebration is in order that I,
I apparently have a new stepmom.
Really?
Yeah.
You sent me this image.
Does this right?
I think she's a little older and then what I'm talking about.
Okay.
So apparently my dad married a Vietnamese woman.
He met online and uh,
she's 34
now.
Make sure you end gang.
There's my,
there's my new mom guys,
don't you dare make fun of my new motto.
Right.
So,
and we've been watching age gap love,
and it turns out I have a real age gap.
Love in my life.
You do page.
Got Glove is fantastic.
I'm so hooked on that show.
I've never been so into a show on Netflix.
And it basically just features people from all over the world,
which is also one of my favorite parts of it.
It's not just in one area.
There's a lot in the UK,
but they're also,
they go through other parts of Europe here in the United States.
They've been just featuring all these different couples,
men and women where sometimes the man is much older than the woman,
sometimes vice versa,
which is even more interesting I think when you see the older woman and the
younger.
And then yesterday that episode featured an older woman who's married for the
ninth time,
ninth time and she married a guy.
Her knife marriage definitely has some developmental problems.
Oh,
he's touched.
Yeah,
I mean he was mouth breathing.
It was weird.
He was,
it was very weird.
Um,
but what do you think's happening in like my dad's situation?
Like she's 30 I don't know anything about it.
I don't know anything about it,
but I'm just saying like,
I mean it,
it sounds like true love.
It's all I'm saying.
Like you come from a poverty stricken place and you meet like a nice 71 year old
guy.
Like I'm sure it's just,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
go ahead.
This,
the voicemail that she left you,
could you imagine?
We have to have her over for like thanksgiving.
Oh my God.
It's a good thing we're not speaking right now because I can't handle that shit.
What?
Just the language,
the language and then having to pretend like it's normal.
Oh,
that they got married and everything.
Like,
oh my mom is my new mom.
My third mom is like younger than me and what?
It's fucking crazy.
But I don't know anything that's going on.
I mean,
I don't know.
It's,
it's uh,
it's curious to say the least.
I know.
I knew he liked to party online and meet people.
He's very social.
He would take a lot of trips left if she's like,
you want to fuck with mine.
Could be,
I'd be like,
damn,
you're that girl.
What if that was her?
That I can be exciting if she was at check.
Yeah.
She's like,
you gotta Get to Jab.
Okay.
I don't know what's up with my parents and like the remarriage to the,
the like the Third World honeys they bought,
my mother liked Indian guys and then my dad's marrying open defecation too.
You're a,
your pops had a girl for a while.
It's called the marriage would have been to her.
I know you,
it's always a wild card with my family.
Just when you think they're gonna do the normal thing,
nope.
Change leads,
then you're going to check in to find out what's going on at all.
You know why?
You know,
I had to put down a boundary and a,
I have to hold,
I have to maintain.
I think it's only right.
But you know,
I,
uh,
good luck and uh,
wow.
What an interesting turn of events.
It's a nice way of putting it.
Yeah,
that is some,
do you think that Vietnam,
do you think Vietnam is an open defecation country?
I mean,
and in rural parts?
Yeah,
but I think know in the big cities,
no,
I don't think so.
Do you think he really rubs her?
Grabs him?
Jesus.
What?
I think what?
Don't make fun of my mom's accent.
That's how my mommy talks guys.
I have a new Vietnamese mom.
Kimmy has way too old that would never work.
Imagine what she could put on your dad though with her experience.
Kim.
Man,
that'd be a match made in heaven.
Oh my God.
What if she's like,
you better respect me.
I'm your Mama
older.
What would you do if your dad,
your mom dies and like,
that's,
that's your replacement mom,
your new mom.
I can't wrap my head around it.
It's so different.
I mean,
because of their different lives.
My parents in yours.
Yeah.
It's always weird when your step mom's like the younger younger model and you're
like,
ah,
that's creating this so weird.
Well,
yeah,
because everyone's natural thought would be like,
oh,
like you're just trying to get something from,
no,
no.
Wait a minute.
Don't you believe in love?
I love love.
How dare you.
I believe in love.
I can't believe you'd intimate such a thing.
No,
it's all,
it's all on the up and up.
Yeah.
Happy thanksgiving.
My mom,
he make fiber.
You can make funny
first to me.
This is my third mom.
Gosh,
so crazy.
Yeah.
Well we'll see how it goes.
You know,
third time's a charm.
It could be
when,
uh,
when I die.
Who are you going to marry?
This is an interesting one.
We've had this talk a bunch.
You're,
you seem to be like,
sometimes we'll go down like a jokey path and then you're like,
oh,
it's gotta be a comic.
You got to be married to a comic.
I'm sure.
Well,
because I think you'd be bored with someone who's normal.
I Dunno.
I would just someone that doesn't have a warped sense of reality,
I think you get bored real quick.
I would get bored if somebody didn't have a depraved kind of sense of humor or
at least at least would not.
I'm willing to play ball with mine
last night on age gap love.
There's one that was a total four corners,
like she's 50 years old and she was such a fun,
like no fun.
Yeah.
I couldn't be married to that.
You're right.
No,
no,
no.
You died.
I don't know.
I could do a comic again cause just cause you're the only one that makes me
laugh.
Really?
Oh,
come on.
Somebody else can make you laugh.
No,
not like you.
Like we know each other so well and he had to get used to another person's
smells and another person's whole thing.
It'd be such an effort to get remarried,
don't you think?
Yes.
Can you ask for a text?
Yeah.
And this might be the groceries though.
Let me stop.
All right.
We took our little break.
We're back.
Oh.
And I'm so excited because the fan of field is fabulous.
I'm just,
I was going to say fantastic and I wanted to say fabulous,
fabulous.
Phen Fad.
Okay.
Then Allison,
a Rosen's here.
Yay so much for having me.
I love being here.
I love you guys.
You Christina have given me so much advice in my life.
No,
it's all been good.
It's been,
I feel like when you and I met,
we had a sort of like peer to peer relationship and then somehow it's turned
into me just reaching out when I'm like,
I have like looked at Instagram too much and I feel terrible and then you give
me perspective.
No,
are you kidding me?
You're,
you're an inspiration to me.
And you've written a book,
which is crazy.
What's the book?
It's called tropical attire encouraged and other phrases that scare me and it's
a collection of essays.
And my husband did the illustrations inside and tropical attire encouraged.
Uh,
I was invited to a party,
a bunch of skinny blonde woman invited me to a party and the invite said
tropical attire.
I didn't go because I didn't have Tiki clothing.
And that does what pulled you out of it?
Just the,
that phrase.
Just that phrase.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like,
I can't go,
I can't wear a sweater and jeans even though I want to,
so I'm just going to write about it and stuff.
So true though,
that something like that can just turn you off from doing something.
But who are the people who see that and they're like,
yes,
I know.
That's kind of what that,
that particular essay is about.
Just like who are the people who are looking for another opportunity to peel it
all off.
Tell me about how to have the idea of,
did that lead to you get like saying I want to write a book?
Well No,
so I had a syndicated column is actually a fun backstory to this book.
I had a syndicated column and uh,
my husband took all the columns from the first year I was syndicated.
He's very,
very creative and like he'll decide he wants to make something and then he'll
look up how to do it online.
And he presented me for my birthday that year with a hand bound book that he
made himself and he had illustrated each column and he did it cause I had been
wanting to do a book for a long time and I think he did it to show me,
look,
you've already written a book.
And also to show me up in terms of giving gifts because I am terrible at giving
gifts.
He's a really good,
and I feel like that year he's like,
I finally won.
Yeah.
Well,
we've already know Alison Rosen.
She has a wildly successful podcast called Alison Rosen is your new best friend.
She's been at your mom's house.
How many times you've been on our show leak?
Just one.
It back backward.
I wasn't on that steep bro.
And that's deep,
Bro.
Who Played Tom or black?
Jesus.
Must be like four or five years.
It was a long time ago.
That's a long time ago.
Anyway,
this is,
you know what I love about Allison's voice and her whole perspective,
um,
I went to Hooters is the title of one of the chapters.
Goodbye underpants.
No chips,
no nuts.
I feel like you are the Inter,
I do not enjoy dancing.
Like you're the inner voice of every human being,
but it's the stuff that people are afraid to admit to.
Thank you.
So Nice.
I just captured that stuff so well that you're so vulnerable and it's so much
fun and I love it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So the,
the Hooters thing,
that was weird.
Um,
I was on the [inaudible] show for years and you know,
we all had access to the calendar so we could see who the guests were,
what live shows where you know everything.
And all of a sudden one day like Hooters pops up and we had a live podcast
scheduled at Hooters and I had never been to Hooters and I don't think of myself
as a prude and yet I was very uncomfortable knowing that we were going to be
doing a show at Hooters.
Even having not been there before.
I think because I hadn't been there before and I do,
it wasn't,
it wasn't about,
I don't want to be in a Hooters environment.
I think it was that I don't want to be standing next to Hooters women because I
feel like I'm going to be objectified in a negative way.
Like I'm not going to measure up.
You think that the,
the gentlemen there are going to be comparing you to the waitresses and being
like,
that chick's not a Hooters girl.
Right,
exactly.
I guess that's,
I guess that's what I was worried about.
Um,
and then people reassured me like it's really just a,
a wings place with women in,
it's so much taller than that,
Alison.
Well,
I mean it's that so much more than that.
It's a place where dads can go and feel like girls like them again.
That's true.
That's the job.
And then they're like,
hey,
my name's Mandy.
And then they write their name on the tablecloths smoke yet I see.
You know,
that's funny.
You really know the whole drill.
Don't fight at all men because my husband is the one who reassured
me and I was like,
oh,
I didn't know you had been to Hooters this anytime.
No,
it's embarrassing as a guy,
I'm not going to.
Hooters is when you end up at Hooters with a group you,
this is how my mind works.
You want the server to know that you're not like them.
So you're like,
oh,
you're like the cool guy.
Yeah.
That you're not like trying to drop dad jokes on them or like being like,
oh do they make those shorts any shorter?
They're like one of those guys.
So like what I do is I completely shut down.
Whereas some of the guys turn it on,
I shut it down so that in my mind at least I'm going,
you're not being that guy.
So I'll like avert eye contact.
I'll just be like,
yeah,
I'm no,
no thanks.
And when they do like their smiley thing,
especially because that's when the dads really light up,
when she's loving,
she's like,
what?
Extra shrimp sauce with that?
And they're like,
I do.
I'll just be like,
no,
I'm fine.
Like that's your game,
Tom.
Mandy,
Mitzi to fall in love with it.
Cause she's like,
he's not like the other dads.
I feel like he's nagging me.
Oh we learned that from mystery or whatever.
Yeah.
But I'm doing it out of not to get her,
I'm doing it because I'm so embarrassed.
I'm embarrassed to be amongst the people who are acting that way and I don't
want to be thrown in with them.
So you're saying that when you're at Hooters,
do you try to act like,
I'm not like these guys who are my friends that I'm here with,
but are they doing the same thing?
Well look,
I haven't been to a Hooters in quite some time,
but I feel like the last time I went it wasn't like me and my friends were
going,
let's go to Hooters.
It was probably when I was working in a office like production job.
And so you're going with people who you're actually not your friends coworkers.
Right.
So it has like that.
It's a different vibe than we're going out with friends.
And oftentimes when you go somewhere with coworkers,
that's when you discovered the kind of people they are.
That's true.
Oh,
you guys aren't who you're part of the hoot club.
Isn't there a credit card you can have if you're like a dad member of the
Hooters club or whatever?
It is
so stupid.
It's horrible.
Now I,
I had uh,
one of my friends,
this was like the saddest.
This is like who I would,
this is what would drive you from going to the Hooters is one of my friend's
roommates was going like five days a week.
So he was a regular and he was talking about,
he was like,
man,
that's so funny.
She always never has the Napkins you need.
And you're like,
oh my God,
Tiffany.
Yeah.
And they're leaving 50% tips and stuff and you're like,
oh.
He's like,
oh,
they're like,
we're close.
Like we're friends,
you know,
friends.
Like do you hang out outside of Hooters?
No.
But you know,
like the stripper or the likes you same guy also.
The Strip stripper likes them.
Yeah.
I always thought it was interesting.
The Hooters uniform,
the nude nylons with
the white sox and then the orange short shorts,
but the nude and islands was always like really?
Like,
that's just,
I dunno,
it Kinda took me out of the fantasy of clarinet for your purpose.
What is that,
why they need that?
Why is that?
I don't know.
It's,
I think it's a really dated um,
concept of making the legs look nice because when I see,
I see.
I think so.
I think cause it would take out any blemish that you might have the butteries I
see it.
I see.
Like I'm like,
Oh are you from the 1950 [inaudible] or something?
Like why are you wearing that?
I remember,
um,
you remember undercover bosses episodes?
That was an amazing episode.
Undercover boss did an episode with Hooters open?
Yeah,
I think so.
I believe so.
And the episode they did with Hooters,
man,
it was,
they had,
so you know,
like that's like where the president or CEO acts like he's trying to get a job
there.
So either have them like washing dishes and the,
the actual guy that running the day to day operations of this one,
Hooters has no clue.
And he was like hamming it up for the camera and he's like,
hey.
He was like,
all right.
I don't know.
Now we can just like,
these girls think they're hot shit.
So,
you know,
you've got to kind of put them in their place a lot so they don't get a big head
about it.
And he was,
he was,
he was a tope pig in everywhere.
He looked like a pig.
His attitude was pig,
like,
and then he's like,
so I do this pretty regularly.
And he had paper plates and he poured beans on them and he's like,
now we're going to hold them out in front of these girls and they have whoever
can eat the pit,
the beans off the plate,
uh,
the fastest,
no hands.
So they have to hold their hands behind their back.
Uh,
he's like,
you know,
just like pigs,
you know.
And then she,
he was like,
he,
yeah,
he was,
he was such an animal.
And so,
and he was talking shit about the whole time and the man,
then the,
you know,
the end of the episode is where they,
they confront the people.
And then this guy just turned white.
And I couldn't believe he didn't fire him.
I Dunno why he didn't give him another chance.
Like really,
dude,
I mean like these Hooters girls still deserve respect.
Well,
they do.
I mean they're just,
they're just trying to sling some wings,
bucks or are they good at eating the beans?
Couple of,
a couple of my thing.
Hello?
Scarfed it down and I think they actually,
it's really demeaning when Scott make this eat the plate of beans to add.
We asked for time off.
No,
like it now.
Yeah.
I've been to a strip club once.
It's part of like a coworker outing when I worked at a company that sold a
airtime,
like media air time,
I remember that was uncomfortable.
I was like in my early twenties what was it?
I've never been to a strip club.
It's always sad,
like I think in theory I would always get stoked
on it.
Like,
yeah,
let's go to Cheetah's and like,
the clown room or whatever.
And then every time I go I'm inevitably bummed out because you're like,
I mean,
I'm glad he's women make a living and not everybody's doing it for sad reasons,
but I,
it just always made me sad.
Like,
Oh yeah,
I think there was a point at which thank you.
I think there was a point at which I thought it's an empowered thing to do.
Um,
and if you have listeners who do that and feel that it is an empowered thing to
do more power to them,
it's fine.
But I think the older I get,
the more I see it as potentially exploitative and
well I look what's went,
hold on.
It's one thing to make your money.
That's another thing to have to stand and pick up the dollars that are thrown at
you.
Like okay,
at least give it an a.
That's the part that always made me sad.
Like just fucking Hannity or like a person.
She just gave you a nice show and the beans into her mouth.
You fucking asshole.
Like that bothers me.
I think it's a,
it's a place where it's like,
you know when you go out and you see what people are really like,
you got a strip club with people.
Yeah.
Yes.
And you can see the dudes that hate women.
Yeah.
That's what bothers me is that their,
their,
their attitude towards them is like you fucking bitch.
Of course.
Instead of like,
Hey,
thanks for giving me the teddy show.
[inaudible] Nice Lady.
They see the power dynamic shifts at the Strip club where I have the money and
therefore own you and they,
and all their rage kind of comes up because that girl never looks at him when
he's not in the Strip club and that's it.
And that's why that,
that's the dynamic I must feel when I go in there and it makes me sad because I
want it to be sex positive.
I want it to be like a tinny environments of strip clubs where it's like that
what the problem is,
you're not going to know Phil clubs
sample sizes too small.
Do you think I should start going now six months pregnant?
She start getting into it like as a couple our thing six yes.
Nothing wrong with it.
Nothing wrong with that.
So now you're going to say that we actually,
that was one of the first times we hung out before we started dating is we went
to a strip club.
Yeah.
Now what happened was I was dating a lawyer at the time,
a guy who had,
he just finished law school and we were out celebrating that he had completed
law school and it was a,
it was near a Tangier,
the comedy room that I used to run.
And so Tommy Ryan Sickler,
Matt Full Shrine.
Well hello also say other comics.
I don't even remember.
Maybe like Jay Larson.
I go,
come on,
we're all going to,
I'm going to get my,
uh,
boyfriend lap dances because he just graduated law school,
which just goes to show how invested I was in that relationship and going to
touch you.
It's not going to be me.
So
I think I had one foot out the door on that one.
Never offers me that shit.
No fuck no father and my children.
No,
you don't get any of that.
So anyway,
we go to the Strip club.
I don't know what stripper to pick to give him a lap dance.
I'm not that everybody.
All
the other comics go ask Sigora asks Aghora Hell know which girl?
Hell No.
And I was like,
really?
Tom knows over to me.
She came over to me.
I still remember that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember,
I forget the girl you just said like,
Hey,
everyone said you're the guy to ask like who should I get to?
Cause you,
you knew their roster so well no,
I didn't know.
I'd never been there.
But they all were just like,
if anyone knows what to look for in a stripper,
it's him.
And that's what she came over and told me.
And did it turn out to be true?
I don't know.
I just,
I think I was just like,
oh.
And I just looked around the room and I was like,
she looks like she's stinks.
Go,
go.
Ask Her.
How would you,
I mean,
what would,
what would you look for?
Like,
I don't know how to pick good fruit.
You know the question you would,
you would see who like,
you don't want the stripper.
I think who thinks too highly of themselves,
too much self esteem as a bad thing.
Oh,
in a stripper for sure.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
We were just talking about a power dynamic.
Bums us out.
She can't have that self esteem.
Yeah,
no,
no.
You just want,
you want someone who's,
who's game like who's who's down for the show dog
and you know what the rescue dog,
all they want is treats and
you just want one,
one,
one.
He'd give her those ones and you get to show.
So you,
cause there's also the game amongst men where you're picking the lap dance for
your buddy,
but you have to pick the broken.
That's what I did when I went to my friend reds,
a Bachelor Party 15 years ago.
We went to this run down Strip club outside of Charlotte and the lady that
looked like life had just handed or nothing but,
but broken fucking dreams but rip dollars.
Oh you gave her,
she was fine.
She looked like she looked like she had had maybe six,
seven kids.
Everything was kind of hanging.
And she,
ah,
you know,
nobody was looking at her.
I went up to her,
I gave her like a hundred bucks and I was just like,
just sit on them and just keep dancing.
It was like,
okay.
So that was fun to send your sense in a way that suites,
which shows her and no one was looking at her like the way you portrayed it was
very sweet.
However,
isn't the game,
Hey,
look at this fugly lady.
Of course,
you know,
it was done to mock her and him.
Yeah,
it's weird that it sounded sweet.
Artificial husband's good at,
we were all,
the sweet part was that we all,
we all looked at each other with joy.
Like all the friends were like,
look how horrendous this person is that we're sending to our friend.
So that was,
that's all she wants.
And you know what?
That woman's still thinks she's Kinda hot.
That's the kind of better,
I mean that's the only way she could keep doing that.
If she was like,
I'm not good enough for this,
she wouldn't be there.
So in her mind,
that's the amazing thing about
that type of stripper is that she actually thinks that she's got it going on
still to a degree.
So you're not ruining that for her.
I would be the laziest stripper.
Lazy stripper.
Christina lie the way.
How do you feel about ball kicking?
Like kicking a guy in the balls as a dom.
You think you could do that?
Some guys like here's,
here's 500 bucks.
Just keep kicking me in the balls.
Yes I do.
But I think it would,
I think I would do it,
but I think that it would be sort of like where you like going to hammer a nail
in and you're like,
oh,
take it easy.
I feel like I'd like wind up.
Well actually I was always terrible at soccer.
So first of all I would kick I,
I'd miss the balls,
but I would try to like really wind up.
I'd probably throw my back out and I probably just graze them.
But I would,
I would in my heart,
I would want to be kicking them.
Drop lied or Bruce.
So you actually don't,
you don't,
you're not enjoying the element of it that I enjoy.
Which is the,
is it sadistic when you heard somebody else?
I can ever remember the sadistic element of like,
Hey,
this guy wants me to hurt him.
I've got lots of anger.
Were a match made in heaven.
Oh really?
So you're,
oh,
I did.
You could be into this.
I could do ball kicking a fart videos is another one.
I feel like I'm already doing them.
Why not profit?
Easy peasy.
Easy money.
I actually,
yes,
I think I could do it because to me,
kicking balls is not like not a,
you're not really hurting someone.
But I think actual,
you really are.
You got to see.
So yeah,
you're really,
then we have any videos for her lunch.
I mean,
the way I would keep showing you to anyway,
the way I'm envisioning it,
it's not really about full windup.
You kick him,
he doubles over.
Oh No,
I cannot inflict pain.
But he loves it.
He loves the thing.
He wants to keep doing it.
And then he's like,
I'm bleeding,
I'm pissing blood.
You know?
And I think I could handle that.
Right,
Christina?
Your end of that.
I'm not into it.
We don't practice it in our personal life.
But if some guy where like,
oh I'll pay you this is,
this is by the way a fantasy that exists outside of me being a wife and a mother
and being who I am to make that clear.
Not now case anyone's writing any offers.
Right?
Like,
but yeah,
I have some dude was like,
I got this amount of scratch.
I don't like five grand,
five grand.
The Hey,
it's a lot of money monitoring.
I'm not your fucking broken down stripper.
Five grand.
No,
I think you're worth five grand cue balls and enjoyed them being kicked.
I would guess five grants you're going to get with me.
You're going to get pure rage.
I'm going to dress up nice.
I'm going to really put my heart into it.
Like I'm going to come prepared guy just like sitting there like yes.
Yeah,
I know I could cause I know it brings her joy.
No,
no,
it's no.
I think it's cause I have a graph.
I,
when I took a,
you know,
Kung Fu in the park and stuff.
I like punching.
I'm very angry inside and I like to get it out and the,
and that's an arctic release for you?
It's a win win.
He wants it and I want to give it,
you know what I mean?
I wanna I want to get the rage out of me.
Okay.
Where do you normally get the rage out or don't therapy?
I do pull out now comedy standup comedy going to works.
Yes,
it does prayer too.
Well,
you know,
speaking of all these offers,
men and women and everything,
here's an offer that a man put out there,
uh,
on the subway,
just to everybody on the train.
And I'm wondering if you two ladies would respond to this,
maybe,
maybe in your single days,
maybe now,
I don't know.
Let's see.
Hey,
here's $20.
Could we
go,
hey,
she goes to work,
right?
So I'm trying to get it in.
He stays with his mother,
but she goes to work so that the place will be
right.
Maybe try to make it look $20 out of smoking.
It's trick when you
go no,
no flowers.
No,
it's your night.
What do you think?
Did it seem no floss and no stocking and then you hear the floss part?
No.
So he's not gonna.
He's not gonna.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's just like,
here's the offer,
right?
It's like a,
it's a clean offer.
I have $20 you get to keep,
I have weed.
You get to smoke.
I have alcohol.
You get to drink and you get to have sex with me and my mom's not going to be
there and he lives at his mom's place,
so it's probably,
it's clean.
Okay.
That's really nice.
Tonight's the think about getting your book
then to take that offer.
What do you think?
I personally am going to pass.
I'm good.
I mean,
I appreciate his patch.
I love a sales pitch and I got to say it's kind of sexist,
an unfair in our society that,
you know,
gay men can throw this pitch out.
We have another famous clip we play where this guy is like,
hey man,
you want to come over here?
You want to Piss on me being me?
Try it out.
You want a free rent?
Like he just throws it out there and it works for gay guys.
Why can't I work for straight guys?
It's a really good point.
I feel like this is a new era.
Maybe.
Maybe he has some takers.
I mean we only saw him from the back.
Whoever filmed this.
Yeah.
Well they were trying to discreetly,
right?
Yeah.
But maybe if I saw him from the front and I was like,
yeah,
I,
I want us to sit on that.
Do you think there's an age where you may have taken them up on the offer or at
night?
There's probably been at night.
Yeah.
I mean a long time ago cause I used to drink pretty heavily.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Lee.
I would drink real heavily and I would,
if I,
whoever I was dating,
like it was very vital me that they
come home with me or I go home with them cause I was like,
sorry,
it's going to get really,
it's going to get real just like that guy because I'm like,
I don't want to,
I don't want to feel anything tonight.
What I want to feel these feelings and if I go home I'm going to feel these
feelings.
So I'm trying to delay.
I'm trying to put more time in between now and when I have to like have my
moment of reckoning of like who did I talk to and what did I say and how much
did I drink and this guy,
this guy to help you forget for sure.
Yeah.
So there would have been a time
you keep jumping over the 20 bucks.
I know.
I'm forgetting about them.
Forgetting about for you
now.
Why?
Why wouldn't you just go to a prostitute?
One wonders because I don't know 20 bucks.
Maybe.
I'm not aware of how much they charge.
How much do they charge?
Yeah,
tell you're the expert.
I feel like,
uh,
at least $30 I think is the opening bid.
I Dunno.
I feel like 20 is probably well known to not be the amount they charge.
Like a blow job made or you watched that?
I'm that lady gave her pitch.
Yeah,
on the streets.
It wasn't good.
It wasn't a good pitch.
Like depressing.
It's a wrap where she puts her price list out there and what you get for the
money and it was like that's it.
Just as Christ has like 20 bucks for the blow job and the hand job.
You're like,
Geez man,
it's gotta work for somebody.
Must've works.
He's doing it.
Why I like the asthma.
The balls for Becky.
Yup.
Scrum.
It's scrumptious.
Yeah.
That was the only like,
yeah,
I got that deep bro.
Scrumptious
choke on it.
How many shorter street?
Oh 20 that's right.
Well let's look them up,
but this is also I think a level of of prostitute.
Maybe not for
$20 but how excited would she be for that free weed.
Free alcohol.
Her evenings made.
Yeah,
and a nice place to do it.
Now my guess is that she is below that man's standards though.
That's how full of himself he is and it's so,
it has to have work for him at some point where he just throws it out there and
some and then what woman is going to be like?
I like to in front of everybody else,
like a lot of women.
I don't think you know many women,
lot of women
guys are.
I like to fuck you guys actually would go for it.
God says love to fuck.
Fuck good.
If you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move
in,
you come move here,
but you got to fuck the fuck a lot,
man.
It riff free food free.
Right?
You got me,
man.
He has somebody.
Oh Man.
You know,
we've watched this pip probably 40 times.
Somebody pointed out to me that there's a whole lot of shoulder movement in
this.
We never really realized he's actually probably tugging his meet this whole
time.
Yeah,
there's a lot of shoulder movement.
Black Guy like want to fuck 22 what's that?
Shoulder new and then you come home,
you gonna fuck the
men from jail,
homeless.
Look,
thoughts still moving
that shoulder.
Don't Reggie Guild.
He's in a cake.
Fuck me.
I think it's because
I think that video just made a Alison sad.
That's Ron.
Jeremy,
right?
I didn't know that.
Ron.
Jeremy.
It likes.
Oh yeah.
But yeah,
it's,
I don't know.
I think you guys should open up your attitude's a little bit.
I guess where I looked.
Close minded squares.
Couple of squares.
Fucking nerds.
We are
of course a while ago we were introduced to ball hawks.
Hi,
I'm Sierra Sen
and ever since we introduced people to ball hogs they'd been making their own
ball hog videos and sending them into us house.
Really stepped into a unique episode.
Cochon ball heavy.
Oh I actually have a,
I have a sex question based on something that was discussed on your last
episode.
You were talking about double pen.
Where are triple Penn?
Where two guys or three guys are in the same hall.
Is that real?
I was just talking about this with Tom yesterday.
How did like puzzle pieces,
how do they position themselves?
It's a good question.
Generally speaking.
Yeah,
it works.
It works.
What are you talking about?
What do you mean?
Yeah,
and the same hall.
Well how to three dicks get in one.
She's right.
How three first of all,
you got to have the right attitude.
You got gotta.
You got want it.
Yeah.
Life is full of obstacles and you got to just,
if there's something you want to do,
you got to,
you got to push for it.
I mean,
what my husband says he'll sometimes do,
if his team at work is putting resistance,
which is,
which is be like,
but let's say we could make this work.
How would we do it?
Oh,
that's smart.
Right?
You could use Cameron Hanes philosophy,
the ultra distance runner.
Yeah.
Keep hammering,
hammering,
keep going.
Yeah.
You miss 100% of the dicks.
You don't try to stuff in here.
Oh,
there you go.
Send the episode was wisdom,
right?
Their knowledge.
That will be 100% isolated for this show.
Just
you're our new drop.
That is,
it's so true though.
But here's what usually happens I think is that,
so there's a guy sitting down,
I'm,
are we really gonna understand,
right?
There's a guy sitting on the chair behind you.
A woman is seated facing him with one in her.
Okay.
Then another guy comes up behind her.
Oh yeah,
there's two in,
there's number two,
two and you know,
and worst number three number.
That's like doing a real that inside you.
Yeah,
that's,
that doesn't sound comfortable.
I don't think it's
ever comfortable.
Right.
But people want to push the boundaries and the levels of what they,
what's possible.
Well,
if it can come out of there,
I mean it can accommodate a lot.
It can accommodate a lot.
You're right.
That's a really good shoulders and God,
God,
that is nuts that that comes out.
Right.
You saw it happen.
Yeah.
Human being comes out.
What was your reaction to seeing it?
Tom?
You're so removed from the physical part of what's going on.
It's just that like you're seeing a baby,
your,
your baby born,
that you're just,
you're just in,
you're not thinking about,
oh,
that baby came out of your puss puss.
It's like,
it's just that like baby is born and you're just totally in awe.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
somebody could have just tapped me and I would've probably fought,
fell over,
you know?
I mean,
yeah.
And then that nice moment you said when the ego and then I looked down,
all this shit just came out of you,
y'all.
This shit fell out the after birth or the actual shit?
No Shit.
No,
it was a the placenta fluid.
Yeah.
Just look like a,
like,
like a sewage valve had been opened and just
was it purples and reds and
it just,
it looked like,
I dunno.
Ocean water.
It was just like,
it was like,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's just,
did you see the placenta?
I don't even remember.
I was so focused on him.
I didn't know.
It was like,
uh Huh.
And,
and then I was like,
is he a ginger?
Cause that,
yeah,
we had a,
I had a real bad moment where we thought we were got to give him up.
She looked like he might have red hair,
but then it,
you know,
everything got better.
But that was a really rough,
well,
he's blonde now.
Yeah.
He kind of has reddish hair though,
doesn't he?
No.
Hmm.
I don't think so.
Think so.
It's more looks like Christina's.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was a magical moment.
You go there when he recaps to me,
he's like,
I saw the head come out and then the body and then a bunch of shit just came out
of you.
It's like how romantic times like a pool that was really like you,
a lot of stuff.
Now did a Daniel Watch you?
Yes.
And He,
his comment was he just couldn't believe how huge my vagina had gotten.
Yeah,
I imagine.
Did you know you didn't notice that part
or it was like,
no,
because even like when you're like when you're,
I think maybe if it was a stranger or something you,
you start to objectify the x's and o's of the whole thing,
but when it's yours you really like
thinking about your monitoring,
the heart rate monitor and you're looking at her and then you know when,
when the head starts to crown you really like,
Holy Shit,
this is about to happen.
So your mind isn't really going there because you're so in the moment.
Was it pretty fast for you?
Once the head crown and then he was out because it was real slow on my end.
I'm just going to give him ample time to notice the size of the head for it
wasn't fast for me.
It wasn't fast for me there cause I think he,
I couldn't push him out enough.
That was a problem.
They're like,
keep pushing.
I'm like bitch,
I am.
And then she's like,
do you want a mirror?
I was like,
fuck no.
I turned down the mirror to get him out,
man.
The mirror would have made me like clench everything up.
That's what I thought too.
Once I saw what was happening,
I think it would get in my head.
So then I just kept pushing and pushing and that's when the scissors came out
and that's when Tom goes,
he goes,
I saw those desserts come out and I looked away right away of the scissors went
down.
It was one of those like I just didn't want to because I knew that it would be
stamped in my head.
So he's going,
if I can just miss that moment,
turn back as a second later,
then I won't notice it.
And that's what I said is blood everywhere.
No,
I mean it was,
it was,
it wasn't bloodier.
It just was one of those things where I go,
I just don't want,
it's like watching some violent youtube thing and you're just like,
well that's in my head forever and they can't get it out.
So that's what I was trying to avoid that smart and you didn't feel bad at all
right now.
And she's like,
I'm s when she was sewing me up and talking to me afterwards and then she's
like,
Hey,
I'm going to put my finger in your rectum to make sure there's two holes.
And I was like,
yeah,
I don't give a shit.
Put your arm in there.
I don't feel anything right now.
I swear because I did feel a lot of stuff.
I swear my ob put her finger in my butt.
Yeah,
they did.
And make sure that they sewed you up.
Right?
I feel like it was while he,
while I was still delivering him though.
Oh and I can't get up the nerve to ask her.
I saw her recently and I was like,
just ask her,
just ask her.
That's my new thing in life because I really don't like that feeling of regret
of light,
you know,
like the staircase
anyway.
It's in French,
that thing afterwards.
So I'm like just say it in the moment,
but I couldn't,
I couldn't do it.
I couldn't say,
did you put your finger in my butt?
Um,
and then I've read that it could just be a sensation of like the baby's head
pushing off it,
but I'm pretty sure her fingers in my butt or maybe you just shit a little,
they told me I didn't and I don't know if they're lying to me.
I had a salad,
a salad a couple of days before I got to do,
they really wanted to know.
Not that I noticed,
but I'm saying if you a lot of,
come on,
I don't understand how I could have not,
I was really pushing.
Did you shit when you were in labor?
Cause I remember when I first started going in labor,
like that's what happens.
Everything just comes out of you because your,
it's like your body's way of clean edge and if you do this every day and there's
multiple deliveries,
I've seen people,
oh my God,
get embarrassed that they did.
A lot of them,
their auto response is like,
no you didn't.
You know I don't like that dishonesty because I asked,
I asked like right away,
did I shit?
Everyone said no.
Maybe.
Maybe weird how important it is to me to know the truth.
All right.
I have,
speaking of shit and pregnancy,
I experienced a double pipe classic while pregnant.
Oh Wow.
Now I know.
That's why I bring it up because someone is it,
is it your listeners who think that it's,
that doesn't count.
Yes.
And I say don't take this away from me.
Yeah.
However,
then I listened a little longer and now I'm afraid that maybe my double pipe
plot classic is invalidated because it happened while I was sitting on the
toilet.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a pure like one,
two,
three.
Right.
Which I feel like is the like that's the platonic ideal of double pipe.
I think you're right.
It was more like I was on the toilet farting and then I burped and I went,
oh,
that felt really weird.
Oh my God.
It was a double pipe class.
I don't think that that doesn't count though.
It wasn't,
it wasn't just,
it wasn't like nonstop farting.
It was.
It really was like a fart and then I burped in the midst,
so I feel like that should count.
I think it counts.
I think so too.
Yeah.
I think that's still count,
but it wasn't as pure as if I was just like going about my day shopping or
something.
Yeah.
But you also weren't like,
does it sound like you were trying to manufacturer?
No,
I 100% was not.
I was very innocent.
Congratulations.
Certified.
That's good.
I do think you have a good point,
Tommy.
It's the organic happening.
It's like you're not trying to make it happen and then you're surprised when it
does.
That's the true essence of the double pipe.
That's true.
Yeah.
So I would say that Alison earned hers and we'll have that shirt shipped to you.
I can't wait.
No,
here's the ball hog thing I was trying to fill.
Yeah,
sure.
People have sent us ball hog.
Oh Great.
Great.
Well I like this.
Yeah.
Hi,
I'm Alicia and I'm a ball hall.
Oh Hi.
My name is Ari.
I'm mostly
Ari man.
Harry in appearance as a ball hog.
My name is Peyton laboratory and I'm a ball hog.
That man is in his seventies
that's will.
Thanks for making the ball hog video will.
Thanks.
Will.
I'm Peyton Lafferty and I'm a ball hog.
Wow.
Hello.
She really committed to,
she did great.
Like I believe her.
Yup.
She look at the way that she's looking at you.
They'll dead behind the eyes,
but she,
I think she wants you to know.
Oh she,
she's doing it on purpose.
This is showing you she's the ball she like,
cause that's a real ball,
huh?
Colin?
What is mom?
Mom's a ball hog.
Yeah.
Terrible.
Tell me exactly what she is again.
What does Paul Kelly get on
the game?
That's abuse.
That's from Taylor.
Good job.
Taylor is another one.
Dave.
So,
uh,
so what,
what are you,
my name is paint laugh ready.
And I'm a ball hog.
She's too cute to do this.
He's really,
no,
she's too pretty for that stops being funny and starts being real.
I know Marcus from a day.
Thanks for doing that Marcus.
And of course everybody else.
And and Kate Lafferty.
Ari,
sorry.
His Peyton Lafferty fixation actor and she an actor,
a performer,
a strong performer.
Very strong high.
I'm pain Lafferty.
Oh Hug.
Everybody really gravitated to her name.
So why would you not?
Yeah,
it's like a comedy club.
it's pretty great.
Hey Lafferty on patent law for the ball hard.
It's pretty great.
Um,
yeah,
that was good.
Tom,
do you like that?
Yeah,
I can't believe Arie did it.
I know.
Um,
I have
a voicemail,
Paul law firm from our friend Joey Diaz.
Okay.
He left me,
he told me he's a,
he was taking this,
um,
natural laxative as a weight loss supplement basically.
Sure.
And um,
I dunno,
he's in,
he's been encouraging me to try it.
And this is,
I guess his report.
Boy.
How it's gone for him.
Stop.
Maybe our audience would enjoy it.
You want me to call me back?
You know,
I always try to help you out.
Well,
the Amazons or the Swiss,
Chris,
Chris Fabric tonight to watch what happens to your asshole the fourth fucking
day.
Let me tell you something.
Took shit yesterday.
Had to be 62 63 inches.
Weight,
different colors,
bubblegum in the 80s willing,
they shaved their hair,
so I ain't ask.
I should have fucking head wall.
I was like a Werewolf and the fucking twice.
I thought it was a baby fucking possible in the fucking forward with Chris,
you want it for two weeks,
you lose 10 pounds and it makes your body feel like when you were a kid,
it takes all the tops.
It's out of your body,
your shit to come out and different fucking collars,
bubblegum,
bones.
I mean it's fucking this.
I was like,
I should've taken a picture.
That shit yesterday.
It looked like a fucking cane.
I couldn't believe it.
Anyway,
figure about your stay black.
You have the white fog.
There you go.
He's thinking about you.
Yeah.
That's sweet.
It's a very sweet message.
It's called Swiss Kriss.
Swiss Kriss.
Yeah.
Eight different colors.
I'm kind of into that.
I don't know.
I ordered it.
You did?
Yeah.
The Amazon or something.
It's just a like a natural link says lax.
It's like a detoxification and things are useless.
Just take a few pills a night for like a week and I'm going to get worse as you
imagine.
What's exciting?
What do you think is inside of him?
He said pubic hair,
bubblegum.
Everything.
Awesome.
Damp.
Yeah.
Pretty good stuff though.
Is Christ?
Nothing like a voicemail from him.
Not Special.
Very special.
I don't fuck with link cause you know that.
Um,
you know the piss on me guy.
The come over and fuck me people.
Someone's made his him a Tinder profile.
We've got this swipe right.
If you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me and it has it,
the whole thing.
Men from jail,
homeless.
If you're thug,
you want to move in your frank and moving to man free rent.
You get at least in a key,
fuck me.
Piss on me.
Beat me.
Jesus.
See me.
I want to come over today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
That's just Tinder profile from Canada.
It says less than a kilometer.
Yep.
But anyways.
Wow.
I wonder if he's getting any traction on that.
I'm sure somebody would.
You know,
I have a single friend who's on these apps and he sends me screen grabs of these
complete animals and it's like a lot of swingers.
A lot of women.
They're like,
my husband and I want to play that.
I'm like,
that sounds real dicey man.
To show up some,
some lady you don't know.
You don't know if the husband's really on board or not or like he's,
he gonna beat the Shit Outta you.
Um,
I mean,
have you tried something like that?
What?
Craig's list meeting people online?
Yeah.
How'd it go for you?
Great.
I almost got married.
Craigslist is the bottom of the barrel,
right?
For that kind of hookup?
Yeah.
I think you should stick to the apps.
Well that's when you were saying though,
what your friend is found on the APPS.
I was thinking it's weird that we all agree that Craig's list,
oh that's super dicey.
But these apps are okay to just meet a stranger I guess.
But the thing is with Apps,
I mean people sign up with a,
you know,
like there's like an agreement to the terms and right.
You're using your photo and like what's the one where the women women have to
initiate?
So that's another level of member's daughter farmer's daughter.
I know that's a bar farmer.
There's something for farmers.
There's farmers only.
I heard a bit about it.
That's how I know.
Um,
that's in like a lot of rural places where but,
but you know,
letting the woman initiate.
I was at bumble.
I think it,
I think so.
And then there's one that's just for celebrities.
Cod,
Riaa my ass.
You have to be,
you have to apply.
It's like getting into the Soho House.
You have to apply and then I don't know how they approve you.
Oh,
it doesn't it make you want to know if you would be accepted.
Of course.
Want to know?
I will know.
Let us know.
Yeah,
I remember Ashley Madison.
Is that still around?
I think so.
Yeah.
That is scandalous.
Know what they got.
They got hacked.
I know.
And then Mitt ruined a lot of people killed themselves.
Yeah.
Have you heard ads for Madison Reid?
Harry Reid,
my dog named after my daughter.
She's the worst.
It sounds just like Leah Remini though to know that we'll Miss Tara.
So there's this commercial.
They play on serious for Matt.
I met Amy from Madison Reed.
She's got like they Chicago accident sound color.
I can't believe it's not Leah Remini or else I hate her.
I just heard listened to today.
I was a hair thing.
Yeah.
Get home home hair dye kit for women.
It's nice and even,
it sounds like a hookup site,
Madison to me,
but it is the hair dye.
We've talked about this before,
but so many just wrote in about it,
so I'd like to get your take on that.
Okay.
Somebody writes,
Hey,
mommy's longtime listener.
My girlfriend and I recently had a debate that we'd love for you at your mom's
house to settle.
Earlier today,
my lady and I were enjoying a nice shower together and all of a sudden a woman
thought it was disgusting that I used our shared bar of soap to clean my ass.
Bear in mind,
I only ran it along the crack of my ass so I wouldn't come back with shit on it
regardless.
She insisted that it was nasty as hell.
Then I used r that I use are bear bar of soap without the Loofa to clean my ass
and she still needed to wash her face.
I said,
it's a bar soap.
Unless there's a brown streak on it,
it's always going to be clean,
kind of Barv so it'd be dirty.
Perhaps a question for the philosophers,
which is why we decided to email you our favorite jeans and mind the wrong for
using the Barb soap to clean my crack and balls and does the bar of soap get
dirty if I directly cleaned my ass with it.
Thanks for letting us your ears and settling the dispute.
Sincerely Soule and Emily and we are ball hogs.
That is not okay.
No,
I don't think that's okay.
I know that probably nothing can live on a bar of soap.
Nothing.
However,
were they taking a shower together?
As I said,
so he just took the bar soap and then probably put it down.
You just,
you should never do that in front of her I think.
I think here's the technicality.
Wow.
Am I really nice zigging when you guys are zagging.
You gotta fucking take a shower with his ball hog.
Oh,
you want to take a shower real quick?
Die.
If he saw what I got from my own soap.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
So I think that probably it is.
Okay.
Cleanliness wise.
Since soap kills germs theoretically,
but it's just a statically super disgusting.
Do not do that in front of someone.
What about just lathering up in your hands and then using your hands?
Is that what do you,
I know many people,
many people,
many people just use washcloths and that I just use my hands don't.
Of course they opened desiccators use wash washcloths not for us.
We're not a washcloth family.
She's your fucking hand be a grown up.
I Dunno.
I'll shove the entire bar's open my ass and sit down and expect it to be though
when I live with,
I mean why?
I mean why not just blather,
lather up your hands and then you do that too.
I did that to you can,
you can really get in the nooks and crannies.
No,
that's true.
I sometimes what I do,
I'll take the
soap bar,
let's say start rubbing it over myself then then put it down and then get some
more lather from the bar.
But I'll put the,
the,
the bar anywhere he puts the bar up is as and as,
as on his chest,
on his face,
on my face,
on my mouth.
I keep,
doesn't care.
I listen.
I stopped key,
broke me down 14 years ago I had been so broken down by this man.
First of all,
he'll blow snot rockets in the shower with me,
full snot rockets.
He'll piss on me and he'll,
he'll drink coffee right before.
So it's like someone dumped a crap of coffee in the shower.
I mean what you do art,
he fucking,
he practically takes a shit in the shadow.
Spread the spread the cheeks.
Come on man,
dad.
I do man.
You got to spread the cheeks,
right?
Of course.
Well what do you do with the sub,
Christina?
I don't put this bar in my ass because I don't see the under no need.
Yeah,
I put it on my hand and then I use my hand.
That's enough for me.
But I don't have hair.
Excuse me.
Like you do,
you got mashed stuff in there and I guess if you do,
if you apply the bar directly then you're getting more soap in there.
I guess.
I never really thought about it and like I always thought that like,
yeah,
the bar's clean.
It's a bar soap.
There's always like armpit hair on it from him.
God,
it's nasty.
It's nasty.
You're nasties.
Yeah.
I'm just so useful.
It does Daniel not do anything horrendous like this to you?
No.
I'm trying to think of like the gross.
Oh really?
How long have you guys been together?
Um,
we've been married for,
we,
we just had our four year anniversary and we have band.
We went together for like two to three years before that.
Oh,
that's good.
I think I'm actually the mark the grocer one between,
no,
probably not.
He's more,
I'm more into open doors.
He's more into closed doors.
That's the one barrier I haven't crossed.
It means that if he's going to go take like a big all meaty shit,
he would like the door closed and he doesn't want me to know about it.
Oh yeah.
You want him to know?
Well,
for the longest time I said I did,
but I think it's more like I resented him wanting privacy.
Sure.
But then I think Cathy,
I think
that's good.
Awesome.
How dare you erect a boundary.
Um,
there have been a couple of times where the door is actually open and then he'll
like sort of walk towards the bathroom and I'll be like,
can you close the door please?
And I realized I actually don't want,
I don't want,
but you left it open.
Yeah,
I did because I thought he was in the other end of that house when it really
comes down to it.
I don't want him to watch me Shit.
Yeah.
And that's the one thing I don't want Tom to know.
He thought I did.
I was wrong just because,
but you thought you did not because you enjoy that per se so much as you're like
why is there a privacy boundaries?
Yes.
I wanted the,
I had this idea that there should be like 100% x.
I was actually just listening to an episode of,
of your mom's house.
It's like two episodes ago.
Um,
when they hear the surprise of that time when we'll be off.
But Tom,
you were saying that nothing Christina does could ever gross you out.
She could shit on you and you'd be totally fine with.
Yeah.
That was so romantic.
Well,
it's true actually.
That was very sweet.
He's never smelled.
Oh my God,
that's not true.
You don't smell me enough.
I smell you all the time.
He's never had be,
oh,
not even during pregnancy because there's some funk that happens.
That's what I'm telling him.
I'm like,
I just smelled different when I'm pregnant.
My everything smells different on me.
Real Musky.
Yeah.
No,
he doesn't even notice it.
You don't smell it.
You don't have any bio so sweet.
Yeah,
but that,
but Allison,
it's not,
I don't know if it's so much a function of sweetness or that he such as checked
out a pig.
No,
not checked out,
but he's so at home with himself and the horror king and the blowing snot
rockets and the spreads spreads that to him.
The bar is so low in terms of what grosses him out or high rather the bar is
high.
Yeah.
So like nothing can phase you because you're not phased by you.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You're pretty open.
That's pretty good though.
No.
If it's romance but,
but we don't share with the door open.
That is the one boundary and you don't like it when I talked to you through the
door,
I feel like you don't,
you want your alone time,
like shitting in peace.
The less is more because that's my time is your time.
Yeah.
I like to just,
you know,
not talk during that.
Yeah,
I understand.
Yeah.
And I don't,
I don't want you to see me shit either.
I don't like it.
I don't think you ever go through a phase where you did.
No.
Okay.
No,
it's just me.
This is my own thing.
Then I guess.
No,
a lot of couples are very,
I know,
I know people that are are fine with it.
We knew a couple that one would be taking a dump on,
the other one would be eating her morning Bagel.
And that's too much to me.
And talking to him,
he's sitting there plopping and she's just like,
yeah,
so,
and I would see them and I'm like,
cause I knew him real well and I'm like,
you just got to eat that in front of them when they,
and they were like looking at us like,
what?
Like how did you know who told you?
Who revealed that this is what they do or how do I saw I saw it because he was a
close roommate of mine.
Oh Shit.
All the time.
But when they were dating,
I'm like,
you're just gonna stand there and eat that while he shits and she need the
registered as the men frequently shit in front of each other.
Um,
no,
but you know,
there's a thing where like if you're like really good,
good friends,
you don't want it to happen.
But it's like you don't go like,
oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
Like you do it would with like a stranger or somebody.
So it's like,
I dunno,
you just kind of,
I dunno.
It's like a bonding thing.
It's more like a ball busting thing.
Like you're taking a shit.
Yeah.
And sometimes you have conversations and then come in here,
I've got to tell you something.
Like you want them to run into the part of it.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
That's bothers me about the eating of the Bagel.
It's just that you're eating in a room.
Excuse me.
Where there's shit flex everywhere and the air.
Yeah.
It's not a sanitary eating conditions.
Nasty for sure.
Yeah.
I'm not sure I agree with that.
Helen asked you for doing that.
Yeah.
I don't have many like weird things about pooping.
It's up,
but that to eat a Bagel and cream cheese is out and all the guys shit,
shit flex or in the air,
the germs.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's not right.
We think of this.
Hi,
my name's Becca.
I'm Amy.
How are you?
Good.
Oh,
I'm bored already.
Your personal philosophy.
My personal philosophy of rehabilitation.
Isn't that what is that is her laugh?
Isn't that just yes.
Yeah.
I thought that was like something falling over or her fart or something.
No,
that's her left.
Audio is great by the way.
The quality is,
you can tell in the kitchen there.
It's very nice.
Yeah,
so my personal philosophy of rehabilitation.
No,
that's not her.
That is her laugh.
Yes,
it is.
Well,
it's her left.
Oh,
right here.
Girl uses lung infection for,
oh my God.
Yeah.
By the way,
this is too much personal info,
but Christina,
you know who you asked how the home search is going,
the way that kitchen looks.
I feel like we've seen a lot of houses.
We saw
it's an infection.
She needs to go to the doctor.
Yes,
that's a bad cough.
She has pneumonia.
What if there was someone who sounded like that at your show?
Oh my goodness.
I've had a few times.
Yeah.
The funny thing is most of the time the better rule is to completely ignore it,
even if nobody else is,
because it becomes such a distraction for the show.
But I've had a few times where I had to address it.
It was so crazy.
You know,
one time a guy was sitting the front row,
he was actually loving the show,
like the kind of person you want at your show.
He was beating the table.
Okay.
And laughing so hard at even minor things that Andy and his laugh was,
it wasn't like this,
but it was a,
it was a different sounding lab.
It sounded like he was in a struggle for his life because laughed,
you know?
So
at a certain point I was just like,
dude.
And I thought that cause what happens is when you address somebody about their
laugh,
sometimes you kind of ruin the show for them and they start to feel really.
Yeah.
But he went right into it.
He didn't care like so it was fine.
One time I had this weird sound,
it was like
like a Darth Vader sound and I was like,
this is so weird,
man.
I didn't want to address it.
And Lo and behold,
some poor person was on lake
and I was like,
you know there's laws and the,
and you'd hear
[inaudible] she sounds definitely sick.
She used to go to doctors die.
He died with some penicillin [inaudible] selling.
You know what it is?
She was on her way out of like a bronchial infection.
Like she,
she had been really sick and now she's able to go to work.
But it's still,
the remnants are still there.
Gross sounds like FIFA when he chokes himself when,
yeah,
that's right.
Oh,
your house,
your house shopping.
Is that what I picked up on?
We have been for a long,
long,
long time.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We sort of were like were into it and then we stop and then we go get back to
it.
And now we're very serious again.
But um,
it's just hard to find anything that,
uh,
you're going to compromise in one place and we don't want to compromise,
so therefore we won't ever own a house.
Now you'll find it.
I think we will.
Yeah.
Now we saw a lot of houses like that too,
with the kitchen.
We were,
it was when Lj was a baby.
We go house searching.
I remember went house,
we went into it.
It was so sad looking and Ella started crying right away.
We're like,
we got it.
Go.
It can be real depressing.
It really is.
Really is as I imagine other just big cities are,
fuck man,
this is what I'm,
this is my level,
right?
Well,
we will,
right.
And our level has crept,
like the price that we wanted to pay when we started.
It's gone up so much just because it's like,
oh,
there's nothing you can get at that.
You know?
I mean,
luckily it's gone up a little bit.
What we're able to afford it,
but just what was our comp?
It's not even about our comfort zone.
It's just like we're going to pay everything we possibly can.
Um,
and when we were still helping to find,
I don't know,
you know,
it's just,
there's a lot of Nice places that are very small and we want space and that's
the challenge.
That's always a challenge.
La La.
Um,
before we leave the book,
yes,
tropical attire and,
and other phrases that scare me.
Is it available everywhere where books are available will be available
everywhere.
Um,
it is available officially April 10th and it's available for Presale March 21st
so go to Alison rosen.com and I'll have links to where you can get it or just
got Amazon,
Alison rosen.com or go to tropical
attire and encouraged.
Um,
also Alison Rosen as your new best friends.
Get that everywhere you get podcasts.
But a quick way to get at itunes.com/alison Rosen for Allison residency,
new best friend.
Follow me on Twitter at Alison Rosen and Instagram at Alison Rosen.
Fantastic to read this house and I'm so proud of you.
Very proud of it.
Um,
all right.
This a closing song is psycho ball hog by Dj Bill Cosby.
I have not heard it.
I don't know.
Uh,
I can imagine what it's about.
Anything else,
Jean?
I'm just so impressed with anybody that writes a book.
And I said,
guys,
bye guys.
Thank you.
Thanks.
[inaudible] to secure a serial killer.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I just want to smash your
out.
My husband is a psycho.
That's the serial killer tone.
Complete lack of emotion every time was this fucking Sera Caroline.
Most of my brain is saying,
I got to get away.
He's going to fucking hit me over the head with a hammer.
I can't control myself.
[inaudible]
it's broken.